let's go to Nathan it's been a little
while since we heard from Nathan and
seven-one-seven what's going on Nathan
thank you thank you my call David yes um
I was I was wondering if you uh I'm sure
you'd if I heard about Greta seem to
reduce your name and please yes
like was it like who's not the real bad
all right hold on are you playing music
in the background
my sister is playing her violin okay uh
so you see it did you see the statement
I was on Fox News with a guy The Daily
wire host Michael Knowles talked about
Greta and he called her mentally ill yes
I did and I guess he's kicked off with
Fox News now yeah which I think was a
good move by them but just made me think
like why why then did they decide to
kick someone off like if you'd like
Laura Ingraham still this show a lot of
people still have show years ago for any
number of things that you did yeah no I
mean listen I write when you call like
why would active catalyst when you call
a kid who's autistic mentally ill that
even there's a line no matter where you
are the line is different on fox news
than elsewhere and it crossed Fox's
lines so that but you're completely
right I mean arguably when John Carlson
said immigrants make us dirtier and
poorer or whatever like he could have
been kicked out for that the other thing
is Michael knows Knowles was not an
employee or I mean maybe he was a
contributor which I don't know if that's
an employee or an independent contractor
but he's not like a host so it's also
probably a lower bar like you get rid of
them
you said if he was a host maybe he just
gets sent on a mandatory two-week
vacation or something I don't know yeah
yes I don't understand why I think he'd
be interesting if they brought to you on
the show sometime it's like who you and
Michaels and others be really funny to
see yeah you know it's it was recently
brought to him I recently received a
proposal from my agent about doing
something with Michael Knowles and we
both were like yeah there's no upside to
this interestingly enough are you sure I
mean I don't know and maybe you have
your I used to be a fan and when I looks
like on the right wing so
I mean I definitely fact that would have
liked to hear your opinion so yeah I
wanted love to see you talk to Michael
interesting all right well I think that
under advisement Politico how long is
your sister been playing violin Nathan
um she every all my brothers and sisters
play violin we've been playing called me
for 10 years
Wow Oh Katherine times very good yeah
all right I will let you get back to her
practice I appreciate the call okay I
guess Nathan's already gone thank you